so now let me ask you this in a  relationship you have to give time right  time and energy when you have children  you have to give time and energy right  if you felt like you giving time and  energy there was taken away from what  your dreams in money was would you then  why did you not think about that before  you're not married exactly what I'm  saying is when we were initially it was  different right that his goals might  have been different people change I'm  trying to convince him money's not an  issue yeah but Eddie if you were now  putting energy in like you want to put  energy in your business but you feel  like having a relationship is straining  your business would you keep the  relationship or would you uh focus on  business I'll do both because I'm  married to you okay now what I'm saying  is if you felt like it was draining like  you felt like you couldn't give and when  I say draining it's not that I want  money I want your time